[Music]
it's more fuel for the Republican fire
angry at the FBI this is the
weaponization of the federal government
at the highest levels congresswoman
Elise stefanik a reacting on Fox to
special counsel John Durham's report
critical of the FBI's trump-russia
investigation he concludes should never
have been launched of course that led to
the special counsel Robert Mueller
investigation he called what the FBI did
seriously flawed lacking analytical
rigor dealing with politically motivated
evidence like the discredited Steele
dossier GOP Senator Josh Hawley also
tells Fox there needs to be prosecutions
there needs to be accountability and the
FBI has got to be overhauled now top to
bottom it's got to be completely
reformed it cannot go on like it is the
FBI tells Fox it has taken dozens of
corrective actions already but former
deputy FBI director Andy McKay Abe says
John Durham has failed to come up with
anything new telling CNN on Tuesday this
was a political errand to exact some
sort of Retribution on Donald Trump's
perceived enemies in the FBI that's what
Mr Durham has done McCabe adds well he
does regret what the FBI did Miss
leading a judge to get wiretaps on
ex-trump campaign advisor Carter page in
2016. the fact is we knew what the
Russians were doing and had done in an
effort to help Donald Trump so the
Durham brobe into the FBI and the
Mueller probe has the Russia collusion
story back in the spotlight this is the
gift that keeps on giving or maybe it's
going to be like the Alger his battle
it'll never end Howie Kurtz hosts media
buzz on the Fox News channel on Sundays
and he hosts the media Buzz meter
podcast it's like a parallel universe
you have Trump allies saying finally
four-year investigation vindicance Trump
this is the FBI probe was a sham never
should have happened political bias and
all that and then you have much of the
mainstream media which of course are
invested in a very different take on
this because of all their coverage of
what was called the crossfire hurricane
investigation by the FBI
I saw an MSNBC headline it's a dud
there's nothing new here we knew most of
this and four years and six and a half
million dollars and nobody went to jail
and basically saying these are John
Durham's opinions but he doesn't have
much new to back it up okay so let's
let's go through that part of it and the
Durham report not being anything new
do you agree with that assessment I mean
did he really break any ground
he didn't really break much new ground
and I'll tell you why based on you know
somebody's been following it although
you know I used to have all these names
memorized Carter page George
Papadopoulos but now I have to stop and
yeah it's a refresher course we need on
this again oh yeah I mean even these bit
players became household names for a
little while but this is that is years
ago and people forget George
Papadopoulos is really the Genesis of
this because his conversation with the
Australian Diplomat starts the FBI going
in July 2016. yes and then the steel
dossier comes in the fall there was a
report I believe last year by a senate
committee chaired by Republican Marco
Rubio
which had some criticisms of the way the
FBI could not get itself but basically
said this investigation was worth
launching and back in 2019 there was a
somewhat more critical justice
department ig's report that also but
also said there was no intentional
wrongdoing and had a lot of the same
information but you know I think in a
way it's a win for Trump because most
people are just seeing the headline
they're not delving into the
Papadopoulos level and they see you know
report vindicates Trump although there
were indictments against a number of
prominent people including Paul manafort
Mueller was never able to prove the
collusion between Donald Trump and the
Russians you know both sides have a
point but what's fascinating to me is
how very quickly they each went to their
opposite Corners yeah it is always the
way in this uh five six years seven
years now that we've been dealing with
this you mentioned Paul manafort
you know once the Trump campaign manager
in 2016. what they went after him for
and what he was convicted of was not
related to the Trump Russia
investigation it was dealing with his
own personal dealings with Ukraine and
officials there prior to the 2016
campaign which made it even more
frustrating because they got convictions
but not really related to the probe into
Trump
yeah then there were all these pardons
uh as before Donald Trump left office
but there was information that came out
even though it didn't lead to criminal
charge that matter if it was giving
internal polling information and so
forth to the Russians I'm just trying to
say I don't believe the stuff was made
up and keep in mind How can any of us
forget that he is by far the leading
candidate for the Republican nomination
next year assuming that he probably is
the nominee whenever this comes up if it
comes up in a debate or if it comes up
in any other Forum he can just say well
John Durham investigated it and he found
the probe was politically motivated It's
Tricky dealing with any kind of trump
news the media I mean when you bring up
former president Trump there's a lot of
angles and a lot of people and
immediately anyone watching is going to
accuse the mainstream media if they're
Republicans of being against Trump as
they report a story about him being
charged or indicted or this or that and
then he goes on CNN and there's a town
hall and CNN gets you know drilled by
people on the left why would you give
them such a form I mean it's eviscerated
he is he's he is really hard to cover in
the news now
even his fiercest attractors would have
to acknowledge is he knows how to drive
the news cycle he knows how to set the
agenda even if it's bad news for him
remember this is a guy who's indicted by
the Manhattan DA's office and his poll
numbers went up I mean for anybody else
they'd be toast anything with the being
held liable in the E.G tarot civil
lawsuit sexual assault defamation it
seems to roll off him so he knows how to
sort of work the media which puts extra
pressure right now in the media because
those look the CNN Town Hall was an
absolute train wreck and it was packed
with Trump supporters or Hooten and
Holland and so forth but those who said
both before and even after that Phoenix
shouldn't put him on because he's a
destroyer of democracy and so forth I'm
sorry that is not journalism that is
crazy maybe they should have done it
differently yeah I could give you 10
suggestions but at the same time he's a
leading Republican candidate and what
are you going to do not cover him for a
year and a half what would that make
people think about media fairness
yeah so how do and how should the media
handle him as we get closer I mean we
have debates that will be coming up and
presumably if he wins primaries and
becomes the nominee I mean how do you
handle he's a presidential candidate
you've got to aggressively cover what he
says
aggressively fact check him it's hard to
do in real time Caitlyn Collins did her
best but you know there's large elements
of the meeting now that decided years
ago that Donald Trump is a Despicable
figure and they just can't stand him
personally and also think it would be a
disaster would he to return to the White
House which is not an impossibility it
used to be conventional wisdom oh I
don't know three four weeks ago Donald
Trump can't win a general election you
know he's turned off too many uh voters
to do that but now with Joe Biden 80 82
almost before the election 86 the end of
the second term some Democrats are
having to come to grips the possibility
that Trump actually could win so that
puts a lot of pressure on the media I
think we have to at least those who are
not you know never trumpers forever
um Get Back to Basics cover what he says
fact check it and do the same for
President Biden who a lot of people
think it's an easy ride from the
mainstream press how deep a wound did
this investigation
the way the media covered it winning
Awards how much and how deep a wound
for the media and for journalism did
this cause for a big segment of the
population
maybe half of it on the right who
thought that they were you know who
can't stand the press it may not have
liked it before but now they're just
they they can't stand it and will only
watch and listen to the media they
prefer
yeah well I think that whole thing where
we're all in silos and tuning in to the
people who only agree with us is
actually a larger uh problem but it's a
pretty deep wound and here's why whether
you agree or disagree with her or
whether you think the investigation
should have been done or not
the the way that the media for a couple
of years overplayed and over hyped and
over sensationalized
the Mueller investigation only to have
it come up somewhat empty-handed but I
always like to point out that there were
a number of indictments and revelations
in retrospect it's embarrassing so I
think the obsession with that
investigation and the obsession with
being negative toward Trump did a lot to
erode The media's credibility and I
don't think we've recovered from it how
as Republicans want special counsel John
Durham to testify at a hearing about the
trump-russia probe they are also busy
investigating President Biden calling
him a walking billboard for his son and
family to collect money oversight
committee chairman James culmer at a
news conference a week ago detailing
what they say is evidence linking Biden
family business dealings to foreign
Nationals President Biden has claims
since the 2020 election that his family
has not received money from China that
was a lie in 2020 and he continues to
lie while Comer says they have bank
records detailing millions of dollars in
payments from overseas some dating back
to when Joe Biden was vice president the
White House calls it baseless and a
personal attack and there was no
coverage of the news conference on the
network Nightly News shows the New York
Times report was no evidence of
wrongdoing by President Biden it will
change if and when the Republicans come
up with some concrete evidence I mean
even people like Fox's Steve Ducey have
called out some of these Republican
lawmakers go on TV and say blyden crime
family yes it seems like I mean
everybody knows that Hunter Biden by
virtue of his last name was breaking in
lots of money around the world that is
at the least unethical there's also of
course a separate investigation of him
on tax and other issues that's supposed
to be coming to a head soon but nobody
including the Republicans has been able
to say exactly where the money came from
or what Joe Biden had to do with it did
he get any money did he do anything when
he was vice president or afterwards to
help his son Hunter and other relatives
breaking in when I see that I'm going to
cover the hell out of it but right now I
don't think Republicans have the goods
that could change and that if it does
change would obviously be quite a
bombshell in the middle of this campaign
yeah I mean Fox airs the news conference
live other networks do not it's not much
in as I mentioned the network TV the
times or whatever they just say that
Republicans fail to link
President Biden to this kind of stuff
so they're not going to care until there
is that link is that what you're saying
and you and you as well I don't think
the media will be able to ignore it I
think it will be uh like a neutron bomb
going off but
this has been under investigation for
quite some time they don't seem to have
anything but I'm not predicting it could
change and I think you know whatever
biases the media have there you know
they're not going to ignore solid
evidence against the president United
States that he did something that he
vehemently insists that he did not do
Howie Kurtz you can watch him on media
buzz on the Fox News Channel 11 A.M
Sunday mornings you can also hear him on
the media Buzz meter podcast always good
to talk to you Howie thank you same here
thanks so much